Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we're going to talk about a rigorous
scientific topic, none other than the creation
of the perfect selfie photo.
By definition selfies are made by us, which
means that these are typically short-range
photos, and due to the perspective distortion
of the camera lens, we often experience unpleasant
effects like the heavy magnification the nose
and the forehead.
And get this, this technique enables us to
take a photo and after that, edit the perceived
camera distance for it without changing anything
else.
Basically, algorithmic beautification!
This technique works the following way: we
analyze the photo and try to figure out how
distant the camera was when the photo was
taken.
Then, we create a digital model of the perspective
camera and create a 3D model of the face.
This is a process that mathematicians like
to call fitting.
It means that if we know the optics of perspective
cameras, we can work backwards from the input
photo that we have, and find an appropriate
setup that would result in this photo.
Then, we will be able to adjust this distance
to even out the camera lens distortions.
But that's not all, because as we have a digital
3D model of the face, we can do even more.
For instance, we can also rotate it around
in multiple directions.
To build such a 3D model, we typically try
to locate several well-recognizable hotspots
on the face, such as the chin, eyebrows, nose
stem, the region under the nose, eyes and
lips.
However, as these hotspots lead to a poor
3D representation of the human face, the authors
added a few more of these hotspots to the
detection process.
This still takes less than 5 seconds.
Earlier, we also talked about a neural network-based
technique that judged our selfie photos by
assigning a score to them.
I would absolutely love to see how that work
would react to a before and after photo that
comes from this technique.
This way, we could formulate this score as
a maximization problem, and as a result, we
could have an automated technique that truly
creates the perfect selfie photo through these
warping operations.
The best kind of evaluation is when we let
reality be our judge, and use images that
were taken closer or farther away and compare
the output of this technique against them.
These true images bear the ground truth label
throughout this video.
The differences are often barely perceptible,
and to provide a better localization of the
error, some difference images are shown in
the paper.
If you are into stereoscopy, there is also
an entire section about that as well.
The authors also uploaded an interactive version
of their work online that anyone can try,
free of charge.
So as always, your scholarly before and after
selfie experiments are more than welcome in
the comments section.
Whether you are already subscribed to the
series or just subscribing now, which you
should absolutely do, make sure to click the
bell icon to never miss an episode.
We have lots of amazing works coming up in
the next few videos.
Hope to see you there again.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!